tell this story steven stills who wrote
the song helplessly hoping he came to
see you guys perform it right
yeah but we didn't know he you didn't
know he was in the audience no
i introduced the song and i'm gonna play
it and i just see this guy
in a blazer stand up and fold his arms
oh my goodness
caucus head to the side and looks at me
and i knew it was steven stills
and that we had to sing it in front of
him wow
did you get nervous i mean i mean you've
been performing a long time since you're
a kid but do you get nervous when the
songwriter is there to
give him oh yeah yeah and what does he
say what does he yell out
he didn't he was just uh he didn't yell
out anything he just stared at us and
terrified us
but he did come back stage after and
tell us that we had done a good job
that was a big deal did he stand up
through the whole song
um the entire song and he was the only
one standing up how many years ago was
that
um this was during the bear creek tour
so maybe like five years ago
five years ago take me back to that
night before we get into anything else
sure
it's five years ago steven stills is
watching you in the audience with his
arms crossed
when you break into this song in front
of steven stills yeah
go ahead you guys do it now right now
okay
stand up and fold your arms hold my arm
i'll be stephen still
[Music]
nearby a waiting a word
gasping the glimpse is a gentle true
spirit
he runs wishing he could fly
only to trip
[Music]
watching he waits by the window
[Music]
hello they are
one person they
[Music]
each other
stand by the stairway you
see something certain to tell you
confusion has its cost isn't lying
it's loose in a lady who lingers
saying she is
[Music]
they are
[Music]
like an angel thank you
you